In the last video,
we had a large cloud
of hydrogen atoms
eventually condensing
into a high pressure, high
mass, I guess you could say,
ball of hydrogen atoms.
And when the pressure
and the temperature
got high enough-- and so this
is what we saw the last video--
when the pressure and
temperature got high enough,
we were able to get
the hydrogen protons,
the hydrogen
nucleuses close enough
to each other, or
hydrogen nuclei
close enough to each other, for
the strong force to take over
and fusion to happen
and release energy.
And then that real
energy begins to offset
the actual gravitational force.
So the whole star--
what's now a star--
does not collapse on itself.
And once we're there, we're now
in the main sequence of a star.
What I want to do
in this video is
to take off from
that starting point
and think about what
happens in the star next.
So in the main sequence, we
have the core of the star.
So this is the
core-- star's core.
And you have hydrogen
fusing into helium.
And it's releasing
just a ton of energy.
And that energy is what keeps
the core from imploding.
It's kind of the
outward force to offset
the gravitational force that
wants to implode everything,
that wants to crush everything.
And so you have the core of
a star, a star like the sun,
and that energy then heats
up all of the other gas
on the outside of the core
to create that really bright
object that we see as a star, or
in our case, in our sun's case,
the sun.
Now, as the hydrogen
is fusing into helium,
you could imagine that
more and more helium
is forming in the core.
So I'll do the helium as green.
So more, more, and more
helium forms in the core.
It'll especially form-- the
closer you get to the center,
the higher the
pressures will be,
and the faster that this fusion,
this ignition, will happen.
In fact, the bigger
the mass of the star,
the more the pressure, the
faster the fusion occurs.
And so you have this helium
building up inside of the core
as this hydrogen in
the core gets fused.
Now what's going
to happen there?
Helium is a more dense atom.
It's packing more mass
in a smaller space.
So as more and more
of this hydrogen
here turns into
helium, what you're
going to have is the core
itself is going to shrink.
So let me draw a
smaller core here.
So the core itself
is going to shrink.
And now it has a lot
more helium in it.
And let's just take it
to the extreme point
where it's all helium,
where it's depleted.
But it's much denser.
That same amount of mass
that was in this sphere
is now in a denser sphere,
in a helium sphere.
So it's going to have just
as much attraction to it,
gravitational attraction.
But things can get
even closer to it.
And we know that the
closer you are to a mass,
the stronger the
pull of gravity.
So then instead of having just
the hydrogen fusion occurring
at the core, you're
now going to have
hydrogen fusion in a
shell around the core.
So now you're going to
have hydrogen fusing
in a shell around the core.
Let me just be clear.
This isn't just happens
all of a sudden.
It is a gradual process.
As we have more and
more helium in the core,
the core gets denser
and denser and denser.
And so the pressures become even
larger and larger near the core
because you're able to get
closer to a more massive core
since it is now more dense.
And as that pressure
near the core
increases even more and
more, the fusion reaction
happens faster and
faster and faster
until you get to this point.
So here, let me be clear.
You have a helium core.
All of the hydrogen in
the core has been used up.
And then you have the
hydrogen right outside
of the core is now
under enormous pressure.
It's actually
under more pressure
than it was when it was
just a pure hydrogen core.
Because it's-- there's so
much mass on the outside here,
trying to, I guess you could
say, exerting downwards,
or gravitational force trying to
get to that even denser helium
core because everything
is able to get closer in.
And so now you have fusion
occurring even faster.
And it's occurring
over a larger radius.
So this faster fusion
over a larger radius,
the force is now going to
expel-- the energy that's
released from this
fusion is now going
to expel these outer layers
of the star even further.
So the whole time,
this gradual process
as the hydrogen turns
into helium, or fuses
into helium in the
core, the hydrogen right
outside of the core,
right outside that area,
starts to burn
faster and faster.
I shouldn't say burn.
It starts to fuse
faster and faster
and over a larger
and larger radius.
The unintuitive
thing is the fusion
is happening faster
over a larger radius.
And the reason that is is
because you have even a denser
core that is causing even
more gravitational pressure.
And as that's happening,
the star's getting brighter.
And it's also-- the fusion
reactions, since they're
happening in a more intense
way and over a larger radius,
are able to expel the material
of the star even larger.
So the radius of
the star itself is
getting bigger and
bigger and bigger.
So if this star looked
like this-- maybe
let me draw it in
white-- That's not white.
Now what's happening
to my color changer?
There you go.
OK, this star looked like
this right over here.
Now, this star over here,
since a faster fusion reaction
is happening over
a larger radius,
is going to be far larger.
And I'm not even
drawing it to scale.
In the case of our sun,
when it gets to this point,
it's going to be 100
times the diameter.
And at this point,
it is a red giant.
And the reason why it's
redder than this one over here
is that even though the fusion
is happening more furiously,
that energy is being dissipated
over a larger surface area.
So the actual surface
temperature of the red giant,
at this point, is actually
going to be cooler.
So it's going to emit a light
at a larger wavelength, a redder
wavelength than this
thing over here.
This thing, the core, was
not burning as furiously
as this thing over here.
But that energy was
being dissipated
over a smaller volume.
So this has a higher
surface temperature.
This over here, the core
is burning more-- sorry,
the core is no longer burning.
The core is now helium
that's not burning.
It's getting denser and
denser as the helium packs in
on itself.
But the hydrogen
fusion over here
is occurring more intensely.
It's occurring in a hotter way.
But the surface here is
less hot because it's just
a larger surface area.
So it doesn't make--
the increased heat
is more than mitigated by how
large the star has become.
Now, this is going
to keep happening.
And this core is
keep-- the pressures
keep intensifying because more
and more helium is getting
produced.
And this core keeps collapsing.
And the temperature
here keeps going up.
So we said that the first
ignition, the first fusion,
occurs at around
10 million Kelvin.
This thing will keep
heating up until it
gets to 100 million Kelvin.
And now I'm talking
about a star that's
about as massive as the sun.
Some stars will never
even be massive enough
to condense the core so
that its temperature reaches
100 million.
But let's just talk about
the case in which it does.
So eventually, you'll
get to a point--
so we're still sitting
in the red giant phase,
so we're this huge
star over here.
We have this helium core.
And that helium
core keeps getting
condensed and condensed
and condensed.
And then we have a
shell of hydrogen
that keeps fusing
into helium around it.
So this is our hydrogen shell.
Hydrogen fusion is occurring
in this yellow shell over here
that's expelling,
that's allowed--
that's causing the radius of the
star to get bigger and bigger,
to expand.
But when the temperature
get sufficiently hot--
and now I think you're
going to get a sense of how
heavier and heavier elements
form in the universe, and all
of the heavy elements that
you see around us, including
the ones that are
in you, were formed
it this way from,
initially, hydrogen--
when it gets hot enough at 100
million Kelvin, in this core,
because of such enormous
pressures, then the helium
itself will start to fuse.
So then we're going
to have a core in here
where the helium itself
will start to fuse.
And now we're talking
about a situation.
You have helium, and
you had hydrogen.
And all sorts of
combinations will form.
But in general, the
helium is mainly
going to fuse into
carbon and oxygen.
And it'll form
into other things.
And it becomes much
more complicated.
But I don't want to go
into all of the details.
But let me just show
you a periodic table.
I didn't have this
in the last one.
I had somehow lost it.
But we see hydrogen
here has one proton.
It actually has no neutrons.
It was getting fused
in the main sequence
into helium, two
protons, two neutrons.
You need four of these
to get one of those.
Because this actually
has an atomic mass of 4
if we're talking about helium-4.
And then the helium, once we
get to 100 million Kelvin,
can start being fused.
If you get roughly
three of them--
and there's all of
these other things that
are coming and leaving
the reactions--
you can get to a carbon.
You get four of
them, four of them
at least as the
starting raw material.
You get to an oxygen.
So we're starting to fuse
heavier and heavier elements.
So what happens
here is this helium
is fusing into
carbon and oxygen.
So you start building a
carbon and oxygen core.
So I'm going to leave you there.
I realize I'm already past
my self-imposed limit of 10
minutes.
But what I want
you to think about
is what is likely to happen.
What is likely to happen
here if this star will never
have the mass to begin to
fuse this carbon and oxygen?
If it does have the mass, if
it is a super massive star,
it eventually will
be able to raise even
this carbon and oxygen
core to 600 million Kelvin
and begin to fuse that
into even heavier elements.
But let's think
about what's going
to happen for something like
the sun, where it'll never
have the mass, it'll
never have the pressure,
to start to fuse
carbon and oxygen.
And that'll be the
topic of the next video.